I love those people I pray for them I
would to hurt them or condemn them but
men I'm not supposed to dress like women
I'm not going to go along go along with
that it's time to stand up and be a man
of God that's awesome that's awesome yes
I trust the opinions of the women around
me it's incredible you might try it
sometime no you should never trust the
opinions of women that that'll get you
in trouble that's the worst part of this
whole
video you see what's happened to society
since we've trusted women to make
decisions get it out of here you don't
want to answer any of the questions
maybe we'll just we'll end with this
because we're talking about Womanhood so
people could probably shout out the
question I'm going to ask you right now
okay but uh you know that you're a woman
yes what is
that what up guys welcome to the Jazz
cly things YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series before I start
like the video on your way in subscribe
to the channel and get yourself a whb
should a vote t-shirt in the description
okay so today we're going to talk about
a man shutting down some delusional
women with facts I think this is a
Steven Crowder clip one of the OG goats
of conservatism so let's watch the video
isgender a trans woman that could put
her at risk of murder you understand
that I don't I don't understand at all
that you're privilege in the situation
then you said these are the pronouns I
need to use I said what if I don't you
said that's an act of violence yeah I
would an act of violence against an act
of violence against you is a crime I
would consider that I would consider
being disrespecting me as a person and
that's not okay and that's not even
ethical it doesn't matter if it's legal
it's not ethical and I don't know how
you can do something that's considered
unethical you said that's an act of
violence that's a crime okay I didn't
say that was a crime an act of violence
against you is a crime so I did not say
that you said it is an act of violence
against you I said it's an act of
violence and I said misgendering
anyone's an act of yes you said it is an
act of violence against that person that
is in fact a crime so here's my question
since we've now decided we have no idea
how many pronouns there are we can never
know how many PRS there are and to not
use a proper pronoun is an act of
violence against them did you ask my
pronouns before you sat down no I didn't
ask your pronouns rude K walks in every
day he never asks my pronoun I have
trauma now I have trauma trauma trauma
trauma that I will talk about for a
lifetime I haven't referred to you with
pronouns you didn't ask my pronouns
though you just said you can ask yeah
you can ask what are your pronouns but
you didn't ask I'm not into touching
okay I'm not put that out front I'm no
touching no touching no touching I won't
touch you course chest and then we start
walking o who is this oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I can't do this I can't do I'm
sorry I'm
sorry bed God I can't do this that is so
wrong these are some older gentlemen
they're trying to make them die early
with these women
thingies I love those people I pray for
them I
would to hurt them or condemn but men
are not supposed to dress like women I'm
not going to go long go along with that
it's time to stand up and be a man of
God an opinion you have that might piss
that's awesome that's awesome okay
um I don't think the trans movement is
about safeguarding people's ability to
express their gender I think it was
brought forth as a social issue for
politicians to get behind and now it's
used as a wedge issue to weed out
ideologically non-compliant people to
that end I think it deliberately
empowers the most emotional dogmatic
people like those going after JK rling
and Dave Chappelle I mean we we all know
there's a distinction to be had but many
of us pretend like there's not because
we've been told that there's not and
that the right thing to say is that
there's no distinction it reminds me of
Orwell's 1984 where he's being tortured
and repeatedly asked how many fingers
are being held up and ultimately the
right answer is whatever the state says
there is many accept these terms because
it's the path of least resistance set
forth by the people who own and run the
megaphones who dictate what does and
does not make a good person as well as a
loyal Army of shock troops who will
effectively come after you and your
reputation both off and on Twitter if
you step out of line the solution always
seems to be to control language and
Grant the ruling class more control yeah
wow yeah cuz that's what they do first
they control language even partnership
that word is so common now um and it
shows how really the upper like the
elites are kind of controlling the
language that we use that's what
feminists do first they confuse you well
you were looking at tsr's Fantastic
little gender unicorn it teaches
students of all ages about gender
identity expression oh my gosh I was on
the vice panel with not a fan was not a
fan this one this one this HEI whatever
um literally told me that I should just
train harder to compete with men what a
guy and attraction it teaches them girl
I don't even know I literally don't know
everything is on a spectrum and they
should be able to explore and express
themselves and and you say that this is
appropriate uh beginning in kindergarten
I mean I I've worked with parents who
brought it into preschools even um I I
see you nodding your head at that I'm
sure you're very excited about it and um
I I do want to point out that there are
plenty of trans youth myself what is
wrong with this one do you think that's
a guy or a girl I can't I seriously
can't tell I think it's a dude included
who have come out at Young ages if I had
this as a tool when I was 8 years old I
would have been so much more comfortable
with myself I would have known who I was
and that I wasn't alone just to
piggyback on that the signs of I bet it
was like a domineering mother
something's wrong with the mom Foria
develop very young like you can see it
in a three-year-old and by the time
they're four they're what is wrong with
her eyes like why would you pick those
contacts at 3 years old are you mad her
identity is pretty much solidified this
is why so many people are scared to send
their kids to public school it's a known
fact that a child's experience in the
first 5 years of their life has been
shown to have a significant impact on
the developmental outcomes for the rest
of their life and this is the type of
thing they're being exposed to so you
will see the signs of someone who's not
happy with the gender they're born with
very little actually that's not true
that is not true you can suppress it
their gender expression is different
gender expression depends on the last
all the science last 100 years has shown
in boys who who experiened gender
dysphoria between two and three
85% of them simply grow up to be gay oh
I love that you're saying this stud
exact is interrup and be rude I will the
other you don't think dismissing an
entire group of people being rude and
then there are one or two% the
transgender dysphoria persists into
adulthood at the age of four child is
not going to know what emotional
attraction Means versus physical
attraction children do get crushes this
is ew e they're teaching these kids
emotional and physical attraction at
four people are pedophiles these people
are pedophiles I swear a completely age
inappropriate product to be putting in
front of children and and hijacking this
unic there's always they just look like
something with these type of people that
you can just tell by looking at them
that you're saying the same thing think
off even when they're presented with the
facts they just go into defense mode
imagine growing up and your whole life
believing something that is a delusion
it's very hard for these people to f the
truth and when they are faced with the
truth and hard facts it just crumbles
their whole world and they go into a
shell and they go into complete defense
mode because they're not willing to
accept the fact that something they've
believed their whole life is actually a
lie horn concept you say is the age that
you should be talking to Children about
gender so the the gender dysphoria
develops very early in life but between
the ages of four and six children think
very concretely about the world around
them they see black and white oh girls
are supposed to have long hair and boys
are supposed to have short hair and
that's solidified in their minds and
they can't see any other thing it really
isn't until and and their perception of
the world is shaped by what they see in
their family what they see on TV it
isn't until six or seven when they start
to think more abstractly around about
things oh maybe girls can have short
hair or boys can have long ha it isn't
in why would they think that like what
are you telling them kids are so easily
in fluenced it's like they're they're
like sponges they literally like pick up
everything you do it's like why you know
it's funny my mom would always say that
if there was a bad trait about her she
would find out quick because I would
start doing
it you know like because the kids pick
up everything so quick a kid isn't going
to think about the length of hair unless
you're talking about it that age that
you could start talking to them about it
but oh see there you
go pu puberty because if they go through
puberty in the wrong gender it's going
to cause a lot of psychological trauma
you made the point though that four is
much too young to have these said have
the conversation at the signs of
gender she is promoting the conversation
at four what these people really need is
another
grownup to talk to because all they're
doing is pushing their own insecurities
on these young kids that's all they're
doing I mean this woman basically just
said kids should be taught before they
go through puberty so she's advocating
transitional surgery for kids before
they hit the age of what 12 and 13 what
if they Chang their mind after puberty
you've done irreversible damage to the
kids who weren't even they should be put
in jail put in jail for pushing this
stuff I heard one of them was like
sending drugs to underage kids too at
least that oh my gosh guys I wish I wish
they didn't cut this this would have
gone so viral okay on the vice panel
this is what happened I can't remember
what she said exactly but Sydney Watson
was on the panel with me I I can't
remember how it came up but I just
remember she said that's bold of you to
say Eli with the allegations that are
out oh it was do you should we just
believe women and everybody said yes and
then Sydney said that's bold of you to
say Eli with the allegations that were
out that are out against you and I
didn't know what was going on um but I
guess like there's like grooming
allegations that sort of stuff with the
other one um but I'm telling you guys oh
oh oh it would have gone so viral it
would have gone they cut it I was like
of course they're going to freaking cut
it that was such a good TV I tried to
get I was like can I get the unedited
footage they're like no when you
influenced them to go through this
life-changing surgery which could
potentially ruin their lives forever
anyway here a little bit of proof just
how insane these people really are the
blond yeah yeah yeah I didn't know any
of this at the time it was such a good
video trans activist accused of sexual
assault offering hormones to youth a
California based trans activist offering
cross sex hormones to youth through the
internet has a long history of sexual
assault allegations with accusations
from multiple victims including those
who were minors at the time who reported
he abused them Ellie ear 27 is under
Fire after posting his plan to ship
cross sex hormones to young people
through the internet without any medic
oversight or prescription this is where
he posted it on yeah so King's saying
guys how is how are they walking around
free I don't know I don't know um that's
what I said a lot of these people are
pedophiles they're absolutely pedophiles
sexualizing a kid what the hell is wrong
with you and quickly deleted it but
obviously it's too late once it's on the
Internet it's there forever but this is
the type of person they're letting into
schools to teach three and foury olds I
mean it's got to be something seriously
wrong with the world that this has been
allowed to continue why should your
right to freedom of speech oh this is
such this is one of the best videos of
all time a trans person's right not to
be
[Music]
offended because in order to be able to
think you have to risk being offensive I
mean look at the conversation we're
having right now know like you're
certainly willing to risk offending me
in the pursuit of Truth why should you
have the right to do that been rather
uncomfortable well I'm I'm very glad I
put you on this
car you get my point you get my point
it's like you're you're doing what you
should do which is digging a bit to see
what the hell is going on and that is
what you should do but you're exercising
your freedom of speech to certainly risk
offending me and that's fine I think you
more power to you as far as I'm
concerned ex you haven't sat there
and I'm just try I'm just trying to work
that out I
mean ah gotcha you have got me you have
got me I'm trying to work through my
head yeah yeah it took a while it took a
while you pick any any actual woman in
this room in what way do you know that
you belong in the same category as uh I
know because they tell me oh gosh not
these people they're so crazy the you
need them to tell you what you are women
this is one of Matt Walsh's best pieces
of work what is a woman yes I trust the
opinions of the women around me it's
incredible you might try it some
sometimes no you should never trust the
opinions of women that that'll get you
in
trouble V and said they don't see you as
a woman that's the worst part of this
whole
video do you see what's happened to
society since we've trusted women to
make decisions get it out of here did
you say I'm not a woman anymore if who
if most women voted and said they don't
see you as a woman anymore would you
then relent and say I'm not a woman I
would say most people on the planet have
no idea who I am I'm going to trust the
opinions of the people who've spent
their lives with me so you but you are
relying on other people to tell you who
you are is what we're establishing for
context I know you like to think I know
you like to say everybody body is raw
rawing and supporting transgender people
and yet they're still killing their
themselves Etc but I'm standing here in
a room full true people applauding you
and asking questions like how can I like
put out legislation here in New Mexico
you know my home state I grew up in do
you try to reverse transgenderism I'm
not safe and it how are you not safe you
just said you're standing in a room with
people disagree with you and you're
perfectly fine so how are you not safe
like I okay look his feelings are not
safe yes yes I thought it used to be
Sticks and Stones can break your bones
but words will never hurt me but now
it's so for me and if my feelings are
too hurt I need to leave my marriage and
ruin my entire family and ruin my kids'
lives never mind we're going round and
round you don't want to answer any of
the questions maybe we'll just we'll end
with this because we're talking about
Womanhood so people could probably shout
out the question I'm going to ask you
right now okay but uh you know that
you're a woman yes what is
that uh so gender is a social thing it
only makes sense is a woman what is a
woman what is a woman word word woman
Define an go a woman is somebody who is
oh well hold on let me finish the video
I don't I don't know where I'd put it
like I have to finish the video included
and respected and seen and participates
in society recognized by other women if
you speak with women circular definition
that's my whatever okay all right okay
thank you Goodale Dam eats that's what
makes me male no your your sperm don't
make you mail then what does it's a
constellation in reality in truth okay
whose truth are we talking about the
same truth that says we're sitting in
this room right now you and I no you're
not if I if I see a chick guys I want to
tell you a secret I heard that the
interviewers like the people they
interviewed in this did not know what
they were like signing up for I heard
there was like a suit or something but
they had to have made so much money it
was worth it eggs and I say that's a
female chicken laying egg eggs did I
assign female or am I just observing a
physical reality that's happening in the
world does a chicken have gender
identity does a chicken
cry crazy people guys this whole thing
started because we gave women the right
to vote what what a clown world I I
don't even know what's going to happen
in my lifetime like think about it if
Society has gone this far crazy in my
lifetime already what what's going to
happen in the future I don't know but
like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time